[MUSIC PLAYING]
- So I want to thank
the Radcliffe staff
for making this sabbatical
such a wonderful time.
Also, our dean, Lizabeth
Cohen, and then staff.
And also the fellow fellows for
providing a really interacting,
stimulating environment.
So I just realized that suddenly
more than half my sabbatical
is over.
Almost I guess in two weeks, 2/3
of my sabbatical will be over.
I should start contemplating
how to get back.
We have been so
much spoiled here,
so it's going to be a challenge
to adapt to the life in London.
So today my plan is to
talk about two things, most
of the time in this talk.
The first part will be
an introduction, really,
to Bayesian statistical
inference, what Markov chain,
Monte Carlo means.
And then the second part will be
a introduction into coalescent.
So when we got those
two things together,
exciting things will happen.
But then you can see what
we are struggling with.
So I'm going to give you
a very quick introduction
into Bayesian statistics and
Markov chain Monte Carlo.
So first, the concept
of probability--
to mention what probability
means in this context.
It's a very basic
terminology in statistics,
but even today, after
more than 100 years,
it's very difficult to define.
So here are two concepts.
The first was one the
frequentist definition.
For example, I can say that
if I have a fair coin--
by that I mean the
probability of heads is 1/2.
Essentially, I'm
saying that if I
flip the coin many, many times,
the proportion of the times
that I see heads becomes
closer, closer to 1/2.
So that's a
frequentist definition,
with probability defined as
a proportion or frequency.
A second definition is
the Bayesian definition,
and that's basically saying
that a probability measures
my degree of belief.
Maybe when I say there's a
chance or probability of 80%
that it will snow tomorrow,
I mean how much confidence
I have in that statement.
In particular, we don't have
many repetitions of tomorrow.
So that doesn't sound right.
I think we do have many
repetitions of tomorrow.
But you know what I mean, yeah.
Tomorrow is after today.
So this pretty much
divides statisticians
into two big camps--
the frequentist,
or sometimes called
the classical statistics,
and the Bayesian.
Oftentimes they don't
talk to each other.
So with this slide, you
choose one definition,
and you stick to it.
So in my talk today, I'm going
to use the Bayesian definition,
where the probability is
a degree of our belief.
You can be a bit more
specific about this.
And [INAUDIBLE] divides the
Bayesians into two camps--
the subjective
Bayesians-- they believe
we can really talk about our
personal, subjective belief
on ant statement or
anything that is uncertain.
Or the objective
Bayesians, who try
to say that we can rationally
measure our degree of belief.
Unfortunately, I think
the rational Bayesians,
or objective Bayesians,
have lost out.
So now the Bayesian
statisticians,
they tend to be the
subjective Bayesians.
So I'll come to this slide later
on, but as the term indicates,
subjective Bayesians use
subjective probabilities.
My biologist colleagues
all dislike this very much.
They don't like our present
option is to influence
the statistical inference.
But this is very much
in the foundation
of statistical inference.
It's not very stable.
So a lot of unstable ground.
So similarly, we use
statistical distributions
to describe our uncertainties
for any parameter or any number
that we are interested in.
So I want to explain--
I'm starting from [INAUDIBLE]
and if you are a mathematician,
this might be simple.
But I'm not
trivialising too much.
So I will just
tell you that have
one slide with some
equations, but not really many
slides with equations.
I just copy the
equations back and forth.
OK, so we use a
statistical distribution
to describe our uncertain
knowledge about any parameter.
Let's say that in
this example, we
have a parameter theta that's
the probability of heads
for a coin.
So obviously, this
goes from 0 to 1.
So we will describe
the uncertainty
or uncertain knowledge
about this parameter-- we
use statistical distributions.
So I'm just be using
this simple example
to explain how you would read
a statistical distribution.
So basically, you have this
curve, like this where.
The area under the curve over
an interval-- for example,
here it's from 0.1 to 0.2.
The area here gives
us the probability
that this parameter theta
is between 0.1 and 0.2.
Obviously, the total area
under the curve has to be one.
So that's all I did
for my talk here.
And now you can say that
with this distribution,
we think that theta is
most likely around 0.5,
because [INAUDIBLE].
So if we talk about
intervals of 0.1--
so around 0.5,
that interval will
have a lot of area,
or probability mass,
so it's more likely.
Whereas extreme values close
to 0 or 1 are less likely.
With this distribution, we feel
that theta is either close to 0
or close to 1.
OK so, that's how the
distribution is interpreted.
My question-- I'm
not going into this,
but I'll just ask
you a question.
You can think about it.
Suppose I know nothing
about this theta,
except that it's
between 0 and 1.
What kind of distribution
describes my knowledge--
or my lack of knowledge?
Huh?
That's a good answer, yes.
Some people think that this
flat distribution might
mean that you have no
knowledge, but it's not yet
accepted-- that's not true.
So the short answer
is that there
is no such distribution that
can represent total ignorance.
That's also the reason why the
objective Bayesians' a lost
art.
So there are subjective
Bayesians are having the day.
OK, now this is my slide
with a few simple equations.
I'm going through
these, and then the rest
will follow rather easily.
It's a simple case
of estimating--
this probability is called
a binomial probability,
like probability of heads.
However, this was
the problem that's
dealt with in Thomas Bayes's
famous paper, which obviously,
Bayesian statistics
is named after him.
This is long before statistics
as a subject area existed.
So also, this has all the
conceptual difficulties
we face today.
So we are interested
in the parameter theta
as probability of heads.
The theta we have 4 heads
out of 10 coin tosses.
You can say admittedly that
40% is a good estimate, right?
Yeah, everybody can say that.
So why are we spending
so much energy on this?
So the simple answer--
everybody can say we are allowed
to judge some principles.
You can't formulate a principle.
You can say how it works
with a simple example.
If you are happy, you
can apply the principle
to very big, complicated
problems for which you
don't have the intuition.
OK, so if we do
Bayesian, we have
to have a prior distribution
for the parameter
before we can look
at the data, really--
before we analyze the data.
And this is very much
disturbing for some
of my biologist colleagues.
They say that I want
to know this parameter.
That's why I did
the experiment--
I collect the data.
Instead of you telling
me what the parameter is,
you are asking me to
formulate a prior distribution
to start with.
So yeah-- what R.A. Fisher,
the famous statistician,
was trying to do that
without this prior.
But I think the effort is
considered to be, in general,
unsuccessful.
One description is that
he's trying to make omelette
we've breaking the egg.
Now, today we are with Bayesian.
So whether you
like it or not, we
have to use a prior to start.
Let's say that we use
this uniform distribution
as the prior.
This is very commonly used.
As Markov explained, some
people have the impression
that this is probably not
adding any information
to the other parameter already.
Thomas Bayes had a
very long section
trying to argue
that this doesn't
seem to be adding information,
or assuming added information.
But in general, that is
believed to be a failed attempt.
OK, so have to have a
prior for the parameter.
Let's say we have the uniform.
And the component of
the Bayesian inference
is this likelihood--
the concept likelihood.
Likelihood means
probably as well.
They are just English words
that mean the same thing.
But this term has been recruited
in statistics to mean something
in particular.
It's the probability that theta,
given the parameter theta.
So our case, we have
4 heads, 6 tails.
So essentially, you multiply
that probability of heads
and the probabilities of tails.
So you write down theta 4 times.
One minus theta-- that's
the probabilities of tails.
6 times you multiply
them together.
Some of you may notice this--
often sometimes there's a
binomial coefficient there.
That's not important,
so I don't have it here.
So the idea of using
the probability
that theta to help us decide
on the parameter values--
Last year to R.A. Fisher,
this is his paper of 1912,
when he was a third-year
undergraduate.
So when he was 22.
This is still a
fairly widely read.
I wonder how many of
us write papers that
are still read 100 years later.
So the idea here is that
we already have the data--
4 heads, 6 tails.
We are interested in the
probability of heads.
Usually, you use this formula
to calculate the probability
of the number of heads.
Well, I'll tell you the
probability of heads.
You use the binomial formula.
But this is a inverse
problem of going
from a theta, to the
population, to the parameter.
Or going from
effect to the cause.
So it's much more difficult.
Anyway, Fisher's
idea was that we
could look at this
probability, theta,
for different values of theta.
And then the particular
value of theta
that makes the theta we all
observe look very likely
will be favored.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, so we already
have that theta.
And then given the probability
of heads-- like 0.4 of 0.5--
we can calculate the probability
of the theta we already
observed.
I will choose the
parameter value
so that the data we already
have have a high probability.
I can plot this as
a function of theta.
You'll find that the value of
this probability for the theta
is larger when theta is
0.4 than when theta is 0.5.
And then we think
that the true theta
is more likely to be
0.4 rather than 0.5.
It's not automatic it's like
a quantum leap in your mind.
There are also
controversies, yeah.
So not really-- not all fixed.
OK, so we go through
that Bayesian procedure.
We have a prior
at the likelihood.
So the likelihood really--
commonly accepted that this
summarized the information
about the parameter theta.
And then we have the
posterior distribution,
which gives us the
distribution of theta
when we have both the
prior and the theta.
So in a way, the posterior
combines the information
in that prior and the theta.
And the way that we
combine the information
is just to multiply these
two pieces together.
So that's this part here.
So you multiply this too.
Essentially, this gives us
the relative preferences
for different values of theta.
However, one trouble comes in.
When you multiple
these two terms,
this does not satisfy
our requirements
that the area under
the curve is 1.
So in a previous
slide, I explained that
with a statistical distribution.
you want the area of
the curve to be one.
But that's not
satisfied when you just
modify those two together.
In fact, you need to
somehow rescale this
so that this becomes a proper
distribution with the area
to be one.
So the numerator here--
that's called the
normalizing constant.
It's normalizing
the distribution
so that the sum is 1.
So in a way, if you modify
those two and plot here,
you'll get a curve like this.
But you don't really know
the labels on the y-axis.
So what this does is to allow
us to put the numbers here
on the y-axis, so that the
area under this curve is 1.
Yeah, that's my introduction to
Bayesian statistical inference.
I also explained that,
computationally, it's
difficult to calculate
normalizing constant.
So basically, mathematically,
it's the integral.
When you have three
parameters, you
have a three dimensional
integral that's
very difficult to calculate.
So now we're going
to move on to explain
how you use Markov chain Monte
Carlo to avoid this calculation
and still manage with inference.
OK, so Markov
chain Monte Carlo--
Monte Carlo-- the
first Monte Carlo
is the world famous
gambling [INAUDIBLE]..
And those things
developed before Las Vegas
become the top gambling city.
So Monte Carlo, named
after the gambling city,
really means computer
simulation using random numbers.
So very briefly, I just
have an example here
to explain the basic idea.
Suppose we want to estimate
pi, which is 3.14 something.
[INAUDIBLE] we know.
But suppose we want to use
this kind of simulation,
or like gambling,
to estimate it.
We can draw a
square with side 2,
and inside, we draw a
circle with radius 1.
And then we kind of flip for
a little ball onto the square.
And then count the
proportion of times
that the ball hits the circle.
So the square has area of 4,
and the circle has a area of pi.
So the probability
that we hit the circle
is going to be pi over 4.
OK?
So this way, just imagine that
you threw a ball 1,000 times.
You got 780 successes.
I just made this up.
I didn't do the experiment.
You can do it yourself
at home, if you like.
So then the estimate
of pi is going
to be something like this.
So this idea is quite simple.
So there was actually a famous
experiment done by [INAUDIBLE]..
Again, this is long
before statistics existed.
to do exactly this.
So we are, basically,
using random numbers,
as you do in a Casino,
to do simulation.
And then Markov chain,
really briefly--
a chain means a sequence.
So essentially, we get a
sequence of values or states
that have the so-called
Markovian property.
This is also called the
memoryless property.
Written in words, you say
that given the present,
the future does not
depend on the past.
I like this one very much,
because it describes my state
as very, very accurately--
memoryless property.
So let's say that, if we think
there are two kinds of weathers
here, sunny and snow.
If we think that the chances
for sunny or snow tomorrow--
would it depend on
today's weather,
but not yesterday's or earlier.
Then you can just work
out some probabilities
for such transition from today's
weather to tomorrow's weather.
And that means the sequence
of the weather over the days
will be a Markov chain.
So it has no memory.
Given today's status,
tomorrow's status
will not depend on
the past status.
So I have to talk about the
two pieces in this name.
Basically, Markov
chain Monte Carlo
is a computer
simulation [? avenue ?]
that generates a sequence
of values of states
which form a Markov chain.
So I'm now going to use
the coin toss example
to explain how this works.
So this is Markov
chain Monte Carlo.
Sorry my curve does not match
the previous one I showed you,
but this is supposed to show
the [INAUDIBLE] of the prior--
the likelihood, which
is not normalized.
So suppose we are somewhere
with a theta value,
and then we use a sliding
window around the current value
to propose a new value.
Let's say that we
propose this theta star.
So then we decide whether we
will accept this new value.
We do that by looking at
whether we are going up or down.
If we are going up, so this
is our normalized posterior.
If we are going up, we accept
without any hesitation.
But if the proposed
value is to go downhill,
we don't reject
it straight away.
We accept with a
probability that's
the ratio of the two heights.
Let's say this is a 5.
We are currently at 20.
That's the high at 20.
So we calculate the
ratio, which gives us 1/4.
So we can flip a coin twice.
If we get two heads, we accept.
So we accept with
probability 1/4.
So that's the full algorithm.
So every time, you
propose a new value
around your current
value, and you decide
whether you reject or accept.
If you accept, you
move to the new place,
and you repeat the algorithm.
If you reject, you stay where
you are, and you propose again.
OK so then suppose--
this shows running
that algorithm twice--
once with the blue dots,
another with the red circles.
So let's say that with a
red one, I start from 0.1
and propose a value
that's like 0.155.
That's accepted, so I
move to the new value.
And then here, I'm
at 0.322 I guess.
I propose some values,
but they are rejected.
I stay here for quite some
time before I move again.
So those values that are
visited form a Markov chain.
You can say from
that algorithm, where
we are moving into the
next state only depends
on where we are right now--
but not the states we
visited in the past.
So the magic of the algorithm
is that those values
that are visited are a
sample from the posterior.
So if you're [INAUDIBLE] those
values and draw a histogram,
you find that you
have this curve that
matches the curve I showed
you earlier, very precisely.
So I'm going to mention
a few other features
of that algorithm, which I more
or less already touched on.
The first is that
sequence of the states
visited form a Markov chain.
I explained this already.
Given the current
value, you don't
get to know the past values
to decide where you go.
The second feature is that
the [? status ?] distribution
with the chain is the posterior.
What this means is
that, in the long run,
we will be visiting the
peak of the mountain
more than the deep valleys.
Remember, it's more or less
a hill climbing algorithm.
It tends to go uphill.
But if it's going downhill,
it tends to hesitate.
So it will spend more
time around the peak.
So mathematically, you can
prove that, actually, you're
just visiting the
distribution correctly.
A third feature
of this algorithm
is that you don't need
to know the posterior--
the normalized
posterior distribution.
You can run this
algorithm as nice
as you can calculate the
ratio of the two posters.
So the reason I hesitate a
little bit to write this--
I copied this formula
from the previous slide.
So to decide whether
we accept or reject,
we need to calculate the
ratio of the posterior
for the new value
of the parameter
with the posterior
of the old value.
So in the formula, we
had this thing here
that's the numerator--
so it's a denominator that
occurs here, so we cancel this.
So I think many of us left
school a long time ago.
So I went to the internet
to search for some intuitive
explanations of rules
of cancellation,
and I found something
very exciting to show you.
Here, this is-- uh, yeah.
This-- OK.
This is probably applying
cancellation too aggressively.
But you get an idea.
Anyway, so the
cancellation here is valid,
and so we carry on
with the algorithm.
You may also be interested to
know that this Markov chain
Monte Carlo algorithm is the
byproduct of the hydrogen bomb
project.
Maybe this is the best
outcome of that project.
The paper was published in 1953
by several famous physicists
working in Los
Alamos on the H-bomb.
OK, so this is my introduction
to Bayesian statistics.
Now I'm going to talk about
genetics and coalescent.
So we have 22 chromosomes here.
They are called autosomes, plus
another pair of chromosomes
that are called the sex
chromosomes, X and Y.
So in the kind of work
we do, we use genetics,
there's chromosomes,
or the DNA sequences
to trace the genealogical
histories of individuals
or human populations.
So you can imagine
that the Y chromosome
traces the paternal history.
So each boy has a father.
The father has a father.
So if you trace
that paternal line,
you can basically
trace the history.
So for two boys, you can
trace the parental lineages
until you find a great
great grandfather.
The same thing for the female.
You can use the
mitochondrial genome
to trace the maternal history.
Now. for the autosomes,
you have two chromosomes,
one from the mom,
another from the dad.
And they have a complicated
process of recombination.
And as a result, the different
segments of the genome
can give us different histories.
This is like recombination.
So in my talk here,
there are different ways
of analyzing the data.
In my talk here,
I will just focus
on short segments in the
autosomes, so that the size--
each segment has one history.
But then different
segments have more or less
independent histories.
So we are going to use the short
DNA sequences in the genome
to look at the
genealogical relationships
and to trace the history.
So here is one imaginary case.
We talk about population
of only 10 individuals.
It's a very small. population.
Each individual
has two sequences.
We can imagine those two
are from one individual,
and then these are from another.
So in the traditional population
genetics, time runs forward.
So those other generations--
so the sequences
[INAUDIBLE] descendents.
My parents have children.
But we turn these process
backwards in time.
We focus on a sample--
let's say we have five
sequences we sample today,
and then we'll trace
their genealogical history
backwards in time.
So then we have this process
that's called coalescent.
So coalescent basically
means the joining
of the sequences when we
found the common ancestor.
This model here is called
the Fisher-Wright model,
and this backwards view
of the same process
is called the coalescent.
Let's go to some pictures
here, that's Fisher-Wright.
And this is John Kingman, who's
responsible for the development
of the coalescent.
Fisher is both a statistician
and a geneticist.
Not ordinary ones, I suppose.
So for two sequences, it takes
an average 2N generations
for them to find
a common ancestor.
So maybe intuitively, you can
think about a small village
where they have
inbreeding-- they don't
marry with outside people.
And then you can imagine that
over just a few generations,
two people will find a
grandma or great grandma.
So coalescent happens much
faster in a small population.
So the average waiting
time for the two sequences
is 2N, which is the number
of sequences, basically.
So this explains that
the population size
determines the rate at which
the coalescent happens.
Just as a reference, for
the human population,
we have the estimate of
the average difference
between-- added to
human sequences.
So that's slightly less than
1 difference per 1,000 size,
or per KB.
So this genetic
variation measure
is calculated using
this result here.
So the average waiting
time is 2N generations.
If the the mutation rate
is mu per generation,
you just multiply the
time with the rate
to get the genetic distance.
But you have two sides on these
like pedigree or genealogical
tree.
So you multiply
2N by mu by 2, you
get 4mu, which gives us the
average genetic distance
between two sequences.
So that's two
genes, or sequences.
Where you move to 20 sequences--
here are some genealogical
trees, called gene trees,
which we simulated.
The first is that there's a lot
of fluctuation in this process.
So the waiting time
fluctuates a lot.
The other features that--
the waiting time tends to
be much longer when you
have fewer [INAUDIBLE] left.
So on average, the
last waiting time
is half of the total waiting
time for this sample.
So that's coalescent.
What I did with my
collaborator, Bruce Rannala,
is to extend this to
the multispecies case.
So the extension is
very, very much trivial.
So here we have two species
of populations A and B.
So basically, when you
have sequences from A,
they can coalesce when
you go backwards in time.
But sequence from A-- they can
not coalesce from sequences
from B. You have to wait until
you reach the common ancestor.
So apart from that, it's very
much the single population
coalescing.
So I'm going to show you
some results concerning
human, chimp, gorilla--
these great apes.
So I use the George W.
Bush as our representative
of the human.
But it doesn't matter
who you use there.
But you can tell this
slide is quite old.
I just feel like some people
feel nostalgic I think.
OK, so if you have a human
sequence, a chimp sequence,
a gorilla sequence
from one segment,
you make it a genealogical tree
that's like the red one here.
But if you look at another
segment of the genome,
you may have a tree that
looks like the blue one here.
So they are all
three possibilities,
which are listed here.
So in this particular case, we
have a very stable estimate.
So the human, chimp
are close to each other
in terms of the relationships.
So 70% of genomic regions
will share this relationship.
But 30% of the other
genome convergence--
the sequences have a different
relationship with the species.
To many people, this
looks very surprising.
But that's a very
stable estimate.
So this multispecies
coalescent is very much similar
to the single species
version, except that we
have species
divergence times here,
as well as the population
size parameters which set
that rate of the coalescent.
OK, so we are using this
multispecies coalescent
to make many kinds
of inferences.
For example, we can do
species delimitation,
like trying to work out whether
you have one species or two.
We can estimate the phylogeny
or the phylogenetic tree
of the species.
Quite a few of these
Judith mentioned already.
So I'm just going to
show you a few slides.
This one's somebody's
analysis using these methods
to decide that there were
four giraffe species rather
than one.
Species delimitation is one of
the most controversial areas
in biology, so
this also generated
a lot of controversies.
So the theta we have,
I did like this, just
to give you a rough
idea of what we do.
You have the sequence
alignment from the genomes,
and then we have
some kind of a model
to describe the changes of these
so-called nucleotides, T, C, A,
G, during the evolution.
Essentially we have
the species phylogeny.
Given the species
phylogeny, we have
this gene genealogy
describing the relationship
of the sequences.
And then we use models to
calculate the probabilities.
So again, we have to deal
with a prior likelihood, which
give us the posterior.
The algorithm is very much like
that hill-climbing algorithm.
I'm not going into the details,
but you just change something
in the program.
You decide whether you are
going to accept or reject,
and in the long run,
you will be visiting
the species tree in
proportion to their posterior.
So I'm going just to show you--
yes, some of those
algorithms for introducing
changes can be very complex.
So that's basically what
we spend our time on.
So I'm just going to show you
one example about the gibbons.
So those two are one
species, and then there
are four genera of gibbons.
The phylogeny
among these gibbons
are very much
[INAUDIBLE] very messy.
So this indicates the
messiness of the--
difficulty of working
out the relationships.
So we managed to use our program
to analyze this large data
set-- to get a tree.
So I think I'm going to
just quickly run to the end.
So we got our tree, and that
seems to be very reliable.
And we did some
simulations to share
that the answers are trustable.
The multispecies coalescent
provides a powerful framework
for analysis of the
genetic sequence theta.
There are two approaches
in using the framework
to analyze real data.
Some people go for the
quick and dirty methods,
but they are very powerful and
can manage large data sets.
We are going for the more
delicate, sophisticated method,
but we have a lot of trouble
with the computation.
Our programs typically
run for a few weeks--
sometimes a few months.
OK, so I'm going
to just acknowledge
my collaborator Bruce Rannala.
He'll actually be visiting
here next month, in case
you want to talk with him.
So we are developing
those methods.
Chengmin did the analysis
of the gibbon data.
So I'll just show you
one of his slides here.
People analyzing
the-- this is a flux
to work on their phylogenies.
I like this, because they
are also playing a card game,
apparently.
They're just having some kind
of tricks under the table.
I think they are supposed to
mean that the species actually
hybridized.
But here I like it
because the gambling,
in the same way that we rely
on those methods developed
in the context of gambling to
make genetic [? inferences. ?]
Sorry, I'm a bit
rushed at the end.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]